uh hey have you got did you guys see the
uh there's a picture that was making the
rounds
um on the internet uh
of uh kawhi leonard holding
two and they were making a big deal
about him holding two bottles at once in
one hand
that is incredible is it it's incredible
i mean how easily he's doing it
you know his hands are like like he's
holding like look
it's just a while oh no yeah incredible
do it hey that's same thing that's not
early it wasn't like that
it was like that wasn't two bottles like
this
perfect picture again look at that
actually ernie's got it even though
look at the one and when he's walking
off the plane he's got one and now do
that
hold one in one foot the one he's on the
bench he's got one in his hand and one
in his fingers i'll stop it
come on man that's easier like that your
big dummy
no you can do that too come on kenny you
know because i thought i thought it
would be a real change it was wrapped
around
especially especially because
you once measured your hand against
against kawhi
all right the claw uh
let's see
no here might as well chuck dr jay got
hands like that dr jay got the most
amazing
shack hands bigger than his how many how
many bottles how many bottles can you
hold in one hand
here's here's a couple well i was just
touching all those so
let's be let's be right and i'll keep
those you can't do more than two it's
impossible
jack has jack he's squeezing not with a
finger in between though
oh you can't no okay so
not like that either that's not how you
do it
you just gotta say you gotta hold them
on the side you gotta hold them down you
gotta hold all you know i'm holding them
that's
fine like this i'm holding them look
i i'll give it to them that's that that
counts
yeah yeah try to drink them all at the
same time
no don't talk yeah he's gonna get soaked
he all gets soaked do we have another
segment because he's going
to go soak this season oh my goodness
that is impressive that is impressive
that's some hydration right there hey
i'm gonna tell you hey that's gonna be a
meme that's all i'm gonna tell you chad
he could have finished it if he hadn't
said that that's all i would say
[Laughter]
whoa whoa
let it go it's impressive dr o'neal uh
chuckster i have a question for you
yes sir because i was watching the show
last week
and um and you were talking football
yeah because
i know football is ranks right up there
among your favorite things yeah
i knew that was coming come on man hey
man excuse me
are you done yeah i'm not okay